Setting up email notifications can help you keep up to date with your organization's security
posture. When you configure email notifications for a site, Burpsuite Enterprise Edition sends
a scan summary report to your nominated users as soon as a scan of that site finishes. Please
note your SMTP server must be connected to Burpsuite Enterprise Edition in order for you
to set up email notifications. For more information on how to set up your SMTP server, please see
our documentation configuring your SMTP server. To set up email notifications when creating
a new site, navigate to the site's page and select new site. Scroll down to the scan settings
section and select the scan notifications tab. You can now add the recipient email address
and click save. If required, you can specify additional email addresses using the plus button.
To set up email notifications for an existing site, navigate to your site's page, select
an existing site, select the details tab and then edit. We can then scroll down to the scan
settings section and select the scan notifications. We can repeat the process to add email recipients.
Thank you.